bonsoir
notre invité de ce soir est l'homme le
plus important du gouvernement de
monsieur chirac stratège politique qu'on
lui donne la définition dès 1983 du
concept de cohabitation stratégie
économique il pilote lui-même la
politique économique libérale appliquée
par la coalition au pouvoir avec le
titre de ministre d'état ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
privatisation 6 assists sur ce dernier
mot monsieur le ministre d'état
c'est que la privatisation c'est le
grand projet de votre règne là dans
votre livre je crois en l'homme plus qu
en l'état
vous écrivez la révolution française à
diffuser la propriété de la terre
nous voulons diffuser la propriété de
l'industrie la propriété des entreprises
c'est la même inspiration construire un
nouvel équilibre politique et sociale
afin que notre pays se détournent mieux
et plus vite des discordes du passé
c'est donc un projet extrêmement
ambitieux votre livre a été mis en
librairie le 14 octobre
cinq jours plus tard c'était lundi noir
la panique des bourses du monde entier
et depuis plus rien vous avez décidé de
suspendre votre plan de privatisations
alors était-il s'achever celui seul état
de prendre comme grande ambition
nationale de fixer comme objectif
politique à la france
la tâche est une tâche qu'on ait
finalement obligé d'interrompre ce des
pressions extérieures ces dépressions da
monde extérieur sur lequel nous n'avons
aucune influence et aucun contrôle
était ce le bon moment aussi de le faire
alors j'ai noté que vous même dans votre
livre vous fait remarquer que pour
engager réussir des grandes réformes
la conjonction d'une bonne intuition et
d'un moment propice est indispensable
alors est-ce que la morosité des 4
millions de nouveaux actionnaires que
vous avez fabriqué puisque je rappelle
que avant la privatisation il n'y en
avait qu'un million et demi est ce que
cette morosité ne va pas faire tâche
d'huile
est-ce qu' elle ne va pas rendre les
français sceptiques sur l'ensemble de
votre action est ce qu'elle va pas vous
empêcher de toucher les dividendes
des réussites que vous avez pu obtenir
depuis que vous êtes au pouvoir est
assez de tout ça que nous allons parler
on va beaucoup parler d'économie et de
finance parce que ce soir parce que
contrairement à ce que les augures
prédisait il y a quelques mois il ya il
semble bien que l'économie revienne en
force dans les préoccupations des
français et dans le débat préélectoral
alors une question centrale combien de
temps encore faudra t-il supporter
l'austérité en ayant l'impression que ça
ne sert finalement rien de faire des
sacrifices mais ce soir on vous attend
aussi sur le terrain politique
si c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
preniez encore la cohabitation
avez vous eu vraiment pendant ces deux
ans les mains libres pour gouverner est
votre candidat jacques chirac at il un
projet politique et si oui quel le
projet alors tout ça ce sont les
interrogations qui sont dans les
réponses que les français viennent de
fournir aux télés sont dotés les sons
d'ajouter les questionnaires de la
sofres qui leur a été soumis pendant
d'ailleurs le journal d'henri sannier
avec une aide priorité pour trois choses
comme on le voit la crise de la bourse
58% des français souhaitent que voulait
en parler ce soir
bilan du gouvernement 42 bilan des
privatisations c'est les trois
préoccupations majeures
après bien sûr la baisse des appeaux les
différences jacques chirac raymond barre
je précise que je précise que la
question était posée les différences sur
le fond entre jacques chirac et raymond
barre la coopération internationale pour
sortir de la crise et enfin 30 % les
propositions de monsieur jacques chiron
tour avant que vous ouvriez le bal avec
allah duhamel avant de le poursuivre
ensuite avec jean boissonnat et avec
albert du roy une première question des
téléspectateurs qui va être formulée par
jean louis le cède à vos sdp edouard
balladur bonsoir curieusement il ya ici
asvp ce soir presqu'autant des questions
politiques que de questions économiques
et financières
dans cette deuxième série de fiches
beaucoup d'interrogations des
téléspectateurs sur les privatisations
sur l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes sur
les fluctuations du dollar la première
question raterait à la bourse question
de temps n'avez vous pas peur d'un vote
sanction pour la présidentielle de la
part des petits actionnaires lésés
envisagez vous monsieur le ministre
d'état un dégrèvement d'impôts pour les
petits actionnaires là je crois que je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion que
j'aurai l'occasion de m'exprimer et
longuement sur les privatisations comme
monsieur de virieu me l'a annoncé
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire en ce qui
concerne la seconde question là ces
questions fiscales
je voudrais dire que notre droit actuel
prévoit effectivement que l'on tient
compte des moins values qui s'impute sur
les plus values pour l'imposition
mais l'autre constate deux mois va lui
que lorsqu'on a vendu et tant que l'on
n'a pas vendu on en constate pas
j'observe d'ailleurs que permettez-moi
de rectifier ce que vous avez dit il y a
encore actuellement 5 millions et demi
d'actionnaires des entreprises
privatisées il y en avait six et demi il
y a de cela quelques mois
ça c'est la réponse à la preuve à la
deuxième question que vous avez posé
exonérations fiscales ou pas je
n'envisage pas de mesure particulière
mais je dis simplement que tout aussi
longtemps que l'on n'a pas vendu on a
subi aucun préjudice et que si l'on vend
parce qu'on a un besoin familiales
professionnelles ou personnelles
et bien cela s'impute sur les plus
values cna éventuellement réalise et le
risque d'un vote sanction
je n'y crois pas je n'y crois pas je
crois les français bien informée tout à
fait et avisé d'ailleurs l'attitude de
l'ensemble des ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler petits porteurs la témoigner
aujourd'hui même le grand journal
financier américain le wall street
journal relevait la stabilité beaucoup
plus grand des petits porteurs en france
par rapport à l'angleterre
je crois que les français comprennent
que nous sommes devant des événements
mondiaux et qu' ils sont tout à fait
décider ayant fait un investissement à
moyen terme car je les dis souvent que
c'était cela acheter une action faire un
investissement moyen terme
ils sont bien décidés à ne cela ne pas
se laisser influencer
des mouvements et des humeurs qui
peuvent passer bien alors alain duhamel
pour 20 minutes
bonsoir monsieur miss d'état bonsoir
monsieur d'abord une question dont je
reconnais qu'elle n'ait pas de fonds
mais que je me suis posée quand vous
êtes entré avec virieu ya quelques
instants
vous êtes brouillé avec le reste du
gouvernement parce que habituellement
cette émission il ya toujours des
premiers rangs garni d'excellence et ce
soir il me semble que vous n'êtes plus
isolé alors comme c'est vous qui faites
beaucoup des invitations aux non je ne
suis brouillé avec personne grâce au
ciel d'ailleurs je déteste les disputes
par caractère j'ai horreur de ça je les
ai voulu imposer à personne
d'obligations d'être là il n'y a pas eu
de volontaires qui a eu des volontaires
venus
il m'a semblé qu'il valait mieux ne
comment vous dire ne pas faire de
différence à une question cela étant
vous savez ne déprécier pas l'auditoire
qui est le nôtre ce soir monsieur
duhamel je suis persuadé qu'il est très
grande qualité et que c'est vrai non
seulement ce que vous est inconnu je
suis persuadé qu'elle est très grande
qualité que c'est vrai non seulement de
ceux qui sont dans ce studio mais de
ceux qui vont nous écouter je suis sûr
aussi alors je vais vous poser une
question plus sérieux cette fois ci en
ce début d'année puisque vous êtes notre
premier invité en ce début d'année les
français sont pessimistes et un sondage
qui va justement sortir dans l'expansion
vendredi le montrent les chefs
d'entreprise sont je dirais presque sans
forcer les mots anxieux pour cette année
je voudrais savoir si vous qui êtes un
petit peu le le bras civile le bras
séculier de jacques chirac vous pouvez
nous dire si oui ou non
après deux septennats de crise on peut
espérer du prochain septennat que ce
sera effectivement la sortie du tunnel
vous dites deux septennats de crise
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire et
c'est sans doute l'explication parfois
d'un certain découragement ou d'un
certain scepticisme d'un certain
pessimisme
mais cette crise n'a pas été la même
durant 15 il y a eu tout d'abord une
crise monétaire tout a commencé par là
j'espère que j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir
avec boissonnat sûrement je l'espère
bien ensuite il ya une crise pétrolière
une crise d'inflation et puis il ya une
seconde crise pétrolière
et puis il ya une crise qui à ressembler
à quelque chose qui était de la
déflation tellement la laf l'action
reculait et au moment où on pouvait
espérer que le monde retrouver la
stabilité voilà que depuis trois mois il
ya cette fois ci une crise boursière et
une crise financière qui est un parmi
les premières dans les préoccupations
des français j'espère que j'aurai
l'occasion de m'en expliquer de cela
aussi
donc moi je ne suis pas surpris du tout
que les gens aient le sentiment que
vraiment en sort plus que ça dure depuis
15 ans et qu'on aimerait bien en sortir
elle à votre pronostic je peux pas
répondre de façon aussi simple à la
question que vous me posez c'est la
question fondamentale de tous ceux qui
gouvernent dans tous les pays du monde
allons-nous oui ou non tous les pays du
monde et les grands pays du monde
notamment qui sont plus responsables que
d'autres du moins qui ont plus de
responsabilités que d'autres même s'ils
sont pas toujours plus responsables
américains écrit train pour un certain
nombre
allons-nous oui ou non arriver à bâtir
enfin après 15 à 18 ans d'errements de
troubles désordre un ordre mondial
économique et monétaire qui permette
enfin d'assurer la prospérité la
croissance je crois que c'est la
question fondamentale pour tous les
gouvernements d'occident dans les années
qui viennent et j'aurai l'occasion je
l'espère de dire que je considère qu'il
n'y en a pas deux plus importantes et
qu'il faut une fois pour toutes se
convaincre que le monde dans lequel nous
vivons depuis 15 ans a fait la preuve
qu'il n'était pas capable d'assurer une
prospérité durable et se convaincre
aussi que le moment est venu
éventuellement de le modifier alors je
vous laisserai avec jean boissonnat
développer ses aspects qu'il connaît
bien je crois vous aussi
sûrement moins et une question que je me
pose est est-ce que quand on vit dans un
pays quand on dirige un pays dans lequel
le taux de chômage est supérieur à 10 %
et dans lequel on ne cesse de perdre des
parts de marché sur le plan mondial
est ce que on peut en substance
naturellement parler d'une réussite de
la politique économique
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire que
nous ne cessons de perdre des parts de
marché et que le chômage s'aggrave
constamment a dit ça s'aggravait pour le
chômage est pas dit ça j'ai regretté
qu'il soit comme tout le monde comme
vous ont sûrement supérieure à 10% je
lui ai dit que je ne sais pas si votre
question mais invite à faire un bilan de
l'action du gouvernement non c'est
plutôt un diagnostic qu'un diagnostic
parce qu'ensuite vous y reviendrez dans
quoi je vous dirais la chose suivante
elle est très simple nous avons en
l'espace de six ans de 5 à 6 ans perdu à
peu près 100 milliards d'exportations
100 milliards d'exportations ça fait 2
point de produit national
si nous avions exporter les 100
milliards que nous exportons encore en
1981 nous aurions une un produit
national qui au lieu d'être d'à peu près
2% serait très supérieur
pourquoi les avons noué et le chômage
est venue de là pourquoi les avons nous
perdu parce que nos entreprises ont eu
certainement trop de charges qui les ont
empêchés d'être aussi productive et
dynamique qu'elle le devrait et pas
assez de liberté est aussi
et aussi parce que nos clients
traditionnels qui étaient des pays en
voie de développement des pays
pétroliers ont perdu une partie de leurs
ressources et connaissent pour nombre
d'entre eux des crises d'endettement qui
les empêchent d'importer autant
qu'auparavant
or la france était très présente sur ces
marchés que fallait-il dont faire il
fallait réorienter notre commerce
extérieur et l'orienter davantage vers
les pays d'europe
or c'est ce que nous commençons à faire
et à faire avec des résultats qu'il
s'agisse de l'allemagne de l'italie
de l'espagne ou de la grande bretagne
nos exportations vers ces pays ont
augmenté depuis deux ans pas dans des
proportions gigantesques mais elles ont
augmenté et je dirais monsieur duhamel
qu'à mes yeux tout est là ou bien nous
sommes capables d'exporter suffisamment
non seulement suffisamment pour que
notre balance commerciale soit équilibré
mais suffisamment pour avoir une
croissance satisfaisante et nous
résoudrons par là et les problèmes du
chômage et les problèmes de la sécurité
sociale qui ont sont dans une certaine
mesure la conséquence donc tout passe
tout passe par une productivité des
entreprises et un dynamisme des
entreprises meilleur je constate quand
même qu'il y a des résultats
depuis deux ans on n'a cessé de détruire
des emplois dans notre pays alors que
l'on avait détruit des centaines de
milliers auparavant je constate
également que depuis huit mois je crois
le chômage a décru
on m'expliquera que c'est à cause d'un
certain nombre de mesures budgétaires
que j'ai été heureux de prendre car
c'est une preuve de solidarité pour
mettre à disposition de monsieur seguin
les fonds dont ils avaient besoin pour
résoudre les problèmes qui dont il a la
charge
mais il n'empêche il n'empêche nous
avons tout de même obtenu un résultat
considérable c'est que l'économie
française ne perd plus d'emplois alors
sur un sujet maintenant complètement
différent c'est vous l'inventeur le
théoricien le prophète je dirais presque
l'évangéliste de la notion de
cohabitation ont dû parfois l'apôtre
sommes surpris l'évangéliste j'avais une
raison de me dire alors je vous demande
pas du tout un bilan complet et encore
moins un bilan constitutionnel mais un
sentiment politique
la période de cohabitation qu'on vient
d'expérimenter va sous sa forme actuelle
en tout cas
s'achever bientôt maintenant dans à
peine plus de trois mois
je voudrais savoir si vous qui on est un
peu le père intellectuel
quand vous voyez les résultats c'est à
dire un président de la république
renforcer dans l'opinion et un premier
ministre dont vous êtes particulièrement
proches qui en a visiblement moins
bénéficié en popularité
est ce qu'au fond vous ne regrettez pas
vos prises de position et vous conseille
pas un instant pas un instant et si
c'était à refaire je souhaiterais que
nous leur fassions exactement de la même
manière
exactement exactement grâce à la
décision qu'a prise jacques chirac eux
dont tout le mérite lui revient et qui
consistait à éviter au pays une crise
politique grave
le pays a connu la paix civile et un
minimum d'harmonie pendant ces deux ans
le président à sa petite part aussi
moindres - il avait moins le choix
beaucoup moins fait plusieurs
possibilités dans la bohème enfin n'en
avaient aucune qui était très commode
faye a choisi celle d'un homme et
jacques chirac
il a choisi celle là je crois qu'il a
bien fait du point de vue du pays
il a bien fait du point de vue du pays
quant à jacques chirac il aurait
parfaitement pu se tenir à l'écart du
chemin et regarder les choses il ne l'a
pas fait et je crois que grâce à cela
notre pays a connu deux ans d'harmonie
sont la plus grande possible ou de
disharmonie la moins grande piste en
second lieu nous avons pu mettre en
oeuvre toutes les réformes que nous
voulions mettre en oeuvre parfois ont
elles été retardée compliqué c'est vrai
enfin oui on va pas prendre tous les
exemples parce que c'était un sentiment
je vous demander vos feuilles en a un
certain nombre en a quelques-uns mais
finalement nous avons pu mettre en
oeuvre l'essentiel de notre pauvre
âmes et nous avons donc pu en deux ans
comment c'est un changement profond de
notre société pour inverser sa marche
vers un poids de la collectivité trop
lourd à nos yeux et pour l'orienter vers
une liberté plus grande pour tous donc
je trouve que le bilan est tout à fait
positif alors autres alors qu'on parlait
de popularité oui bon oui vous me parlez
c'est une donnée politique importante
oui moi et quelques années vraiment et
quelques jours de l'élection
présidentielle ce monsieur duhamel
fugace mais à trois mois et qu'elle que
je ne crois moi quelques jours mais ne
nous pressons pas trop de juger d'abord
on ne fait pas les choses pour
rechercher la popularité les grandes
décisions de l'histoire de notre pays
n'ont pas toujours été populaire
elles sont devenues après quelques
quelques fois mais mais ça n'est pas ça
allez-vous parler l'élection au plan
général n'ont en général ce que je veux
dire aux élections en général on va y
venir justement en général les hommes
politiques et les dirigeants y compris
les premiers d'entre eux ne déteste pas
être populaire à trois mois des
élections c'est humain alors justement à
propos de cette élection tout le monde à
mettre mais pas forcément à propos de
cette élection
vous êtes auprès de jacques chirac un de
ceux dont l'avis compte le plus sur le
plan politique c'est peu contestable
alors j'aurai savoir à quel moment exact
lui suggérez vous de se déclarer
officiellement candidat puisque tout le
monde sait qu'il est déjà en pratique
mais officiellement le plus rapidement
possible c'est à dire ce sera lui l'envi
des vous c'est maintenant évident je ne
veux pas donner une date qui comme par
hasard serait ou bien serait celle qu'il
retiendrait ou bien ne serait pas celle
qu'il retiendrait dans le premier cas ce
serait trop agréable pour moi dans ce
grand trop désagréable à voir la fin du
mois
je le souhaiterais alors est ce que je
le sois gré puis je vous expliquer
pourquoi en baisse a volontiers je crois
que l'élection présidentielle est la
grande élection de notre vie politique
finalement la plus importante avec les
élections législatives
[Musique]
trois mois pour expliquer aux français
de quoi il retourne
ce qui est en jeu et ce qu'on leur
propose ça n'est pas trop et je trouve
donc que il est normal que jacques
chirac qui s'est imposé comme chef du
gouvernement
une très grande discrétion politique qui
n'a pas toujours été payés de retour
je tiens à le dire de quel côté de la
part du chef de l'état qui a pas
toujours été payés d'euros c'est ce
qu'on appelle une pierre dans son jardin
ce que c'est ce qu'on appelle un propos
très clairs sur une pierre dans le
jardin dans le parc si vous préférez le
parc si vous voulez je considère donc
que trois mois al avance
il est temps pour le chef du
gouvernement qui doit se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle comme vous le
dit très justement ça n'est un secret
pour personne de prendre ces trois mois
pour expliquer au pays ce qu'il a voulu
faire ce qu'il a fait sur tout ce qu'il
compte faire pour l'avenir et ne pas
s'enfermer dans un bilan du passé et je
dirais qu'il me semble que les français
ont le droit maintenant d'être au clair
là dessus
n'ont elles non seulement de la part de
jacques chirac
mais de la part des autres aussi alors
est ce que c'est une seconde pierre dans
le parc de l'elysée c'est pas une pierre
écoute et vous avez là comment vous dire
là des autorisations des pierres
formation maintenance l'obsession des
pierres c'est valable pour tous les
candidats et enfin en simplifiant vous
ne me dirait sûrement pas le contraire
on sait très bien que jacques chirac et
raymond barre son candidat par exemple
on ne peut pas rendre le semblant ne
peut pas en dire autant du président de
la république non alors vous regrettez
que il tarde à
faire connaître sa décision je crois que
le moment serait venu maintenant et que
s'il pleut si je peux me permettre de le
dire avec toute la déférence qui
s'imposent
l'attitude qui consiste à dire chaque
semaine ou chaque jour ou chaque heure
je serai candidat peut-être que je ne le
serai pas je serais si telle condition
est remplie jeu dans les pas très envie
mais j'écouterai mon devoir
j'entendrai l'immense appel qui
éventuellement mon travers moi c'est un
peu lassant et je craque les français ne
trouve que on en prend à peu à leur aise
avec eux et je trouve que par respect
pour le peuple français
maintenant le moment est venu pour
chacun de dire clairement ce qu'il veut
faire
alors l'objection qui fait quand on
tient à ce genre de propos de
l'objection classique c'est de dire il y
aura par exemple au début de février
entre le 10 et le 12
un sommet européen important si le
premier ministre et a fortiori le
président de la république c'était par
hypothèse déclaré avant quand on se
déclare on est obligé comme vous le
disiez de définir ses objectifs
puis on se pose toujours un peu en
s'opposant donc on est obligé de
critiquer son partenaire prédécesseur
adversaires et alors
si ensuite le sommet comme c'est le cas
ce sera important est-ce que ce tandem
ne paraîtra pas incongru le tandem du
président et du premier ministre
adversaire me pas du tout écouté il
s'agit d'une e je dirais d'une bonne
gestion des affaires de l'état et du
gouvernement entre parfaitement être
candidat et se consacrer à sa
responsabilité qui est celle de gérer le
pays puisqu'on en a la responsabilité
sans se laisser aller à des écarts
après tout il ne s'agirait pas des
premiers responsables dans un grand pays
à être candidat dans une conférence
internationale importante
j'étais à la conférence d venise du
sommet des chefs d'état il ya de cela
six mois cette chaire été candidate il
se trouve qu'elle a été lui hier je vous
assure que ça lui a enlevé aucune
autorité partie non mais reconnaît
dirait qu'ils n'étaient pas flanc tsl h
m
opposition c'est vrai c'est vrai écoutez
monsieur chirac et monsieur mitterrand
ont montré qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
doigté depuis deux ans je trouvais il
met aussi with en ont eu pas mal je
trouve ils montreront qu'ils en ont
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de bien
davantage encore alors vous venez de
dire que vous souhaitiez que jacques
chirac se déclare avant la fin du mois
et que vous pensiez que ce serait le
moment à ce moment là qu'ils expliquent
ce que sont ses objectifs et son projet
vous y êtes forcément associé à
l'élaboration de ses objectifs et de ce
projet ça fait partie de vos
responsabilités et de votre rôle alors
je vais prendre une comparaison qui je
pense ne vous sera pas désagréable
lorsque georges pompidou s'était
présenté à l'élection présidentielle il
avait fait une campagne qui avait été
courte qui était de bonne qualité et à
l'occasion de laquelle il avait présenté
un certain nombre d'idées qui à l'époque
apparaissait comme nouvelle qui avait
intéressé et je me rappelle notamment la
proposition qu'il avait faite de la
mensualisation c'est une mesure qui pour
la vie quotidienne des français avait
changé pas mal de choses et qu'il avait
exprimé à cette occasion je voudrais
savoir si vous avez deux ou trois
exemples ou suggestions simplement de ce
genre qui seraient ressenties à la fois
comme des nouveautés et avec des
conséquences sur la vie pratique des
français pas moi
mais jacques chirac les arts et il en
fera par lui même le moment venu c'est
lui le candidat oui mais il n'est pas
interdit aux ministres d'état qu'est le
second personnage du gouvernement et à
edouard balladur qui est un des
principaux conseillers de jacques chirac
d'avoir quelques idées à proposer mais
je ne vous ai pas dit que je n'avais pas
d'idée à proposer mais vous me
pardonnerez c'est à lui que je les
réserve vrai c'est lui quel candidat je
le répète et c'est lui qui doit
expliquer au pays ce qu'il veut faire
pour l'avenir je veux bien vous donner
quelques indications générales mais
genre j'irai pas très loin dans les
détails
commençons par là commençons par là si
vous voulez alors d'abord est ce qu'il
ya un projet de société de jacques
chirac
je me méfie beaucoup des projets de
société
nous sortons dans prend entre monsieur
duhamel
il y en avait un en 1982 projet de
société
on a vu ce qu'il en est advenu moins de
deux ans après au point qu'aujourd'hui
le rappel de ses premières années de la
gestion des précédents gouvernements
apparaît quelque peu je dirais déplacer
incongrus comme une sorte de faute de
goût
quand on appelle ce qui s'est passé va
de soi qu'il ne faut parler que de ce
qui s'est passé depuis 84 85 mais pas
avant vous vous interdire et pendant la
campagne dit faire allusion aux gens
parleraient de temps à au tout de même
il faut pas être trop angélique temps à
autre donc je me méfie des projets de
socié je crois c'est ce que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer dans ce livre dont monsieur
de virieu parlais je crois que la france
a besoin les entreprises les citoyens
les français ont besoin d'inverser ce
mouvement séculaire qui a conduit l'état
à prendre toujours plus de place dans la
vie de la société dans la vie économique
dans la vie sociale dans la vie
politique et je crois que le projet est
de trouver un bon équilibre entre ce que
doit être le rôle de l'état est ce que
doit être le rôle de la liberté il
s'agit pas du tout jeter l'état aux
orties régis pas du tout c'est une un
peu une caricature que de présenter les
choses comme ça il ne s'agit pas d'avoir
une liberté sans fin ni sans contrôle
mais il ne s'agit pas non plus d'avoir
un état qui se mêle de tout et qui fait
tout et je crois que le projet de
société
s'il en faut 1 qui sera celui de jacques
chirac c'est de faire un bon équilibre
entre la nécessaire liberté et la
nécessaire solidarité
comment trouver cet équilibre où ça
varie d'ailleurs selon les sujets qu'ils
soient économiques ou sociaux politiques
mais je crois que c'est la question
centrale de notre avenir
étant observé que partout dans le monde
il y a un immense mouvement vers la
liberté même dans les pays socialistes
on vous parle de privatisation
même dans les pays en voie de
développement on s'aperçoit partout que
le mouvement vers l'état qui a tous
gouvernés depuis 40 ou 50 ans a conduit
à des excès
alors deux dernières questions parce que
je vois que le temps qu'ils sont tout à
fait dans la ligne de sa blessure parce
que je vois que le temps s'est écoulé et
que viriot me fait discrètement signe de
deux dernières questions
d'abord en en restant à ce niveau de
généralité donc vous pouvez me répondre
tout à fait brièvement en en restant à
ce niveau de généralité
c'est à dire l équilibre entre la
liberté la solidarité comme projet
attendez ne me le reproche pas laurent
une question sur le projet de société il
est difficile d'être trouvé ma question
n'était peut-être pas un reproche
le pire n'est jamais sûr bien alors en
restant à ce degré d' équilibre entre
liberté solidarité ce que vous avez le
sentiment sur le fond est ce que vous le
sentiment qui a entre la démarche de
jacques chirac par exemple et la
démarche de raymond barre une différence
au fondamental je ne le crois pas je
n'en ai pas l'impression
il ya sans doute des différends sur tel
ou tel problème précis j'aurais
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler avec
eux tout à l'heure mais sur le plan de
l'orientation générale de la société je
ne le crois pas et leur dernière
question également brève également
reliée à sa manière question la première
idée au fond qu'on ait vues exprimées
justement pour cette campagne par les
socialistes
et à propos de projet de société c'est
la suggestion d'un minimum social
garanti c'est une idée qui apparaît en
france mais enfin qui est déjà utilisée
partiellement dans des communautés que
co faut un petit peu plus large et hors
de france dans certains cas et dans
certaines proportions vouloir savoir si
c'est une idée qui vous paraît équitable
souhaitable et possible sous le prochain
septennat
nous tentons de la mettre en oeuvre mais
sous une autre forme
sous la forme de
d'allocations ou dead délivrés par les
collectivités locales et surtout sous la
forme qui consiste moins à offrir un
revenu minimum garanti qu'un travail
minimum garanti à chacun je crois que le
problème c'est le suivi du travail et
des revenus du travail bien sûr mais
c'est celui du travail plus encore que
celui du revenu mais quand on n'a pas de
travail
à quand on n'a pas de travail et bien
côté nous sommes ceux qui justement ont
pris les décisions qu'il fallait prendre
pour qu'enfin tous les chômeurs est un
revenu ce qui n'était pas le cas il y a
deux ans enfin et pour que tous les
chômeurs est une formation ce qui
n'était pas non plus le cas il ya deux
donc en termes d'équilibré social vous
vous jugé équitable comment vous le dire
on n'est jamais aussi équitable qu'on
devrait on ne fait jamais tout ce que
l'on devrait pour résoudre certaines
situations c'est bien évident mais on
est bien obligé de tenir un équilibre
entre
je dirais le l'équité le coeur et puis
les possibilités nous ne pouvons pas mon
avis aller dans un système qui
consisterait à donner un revenu
obligatoire minimum à toute la
population distribuées par l'état
à mon avis ce serait même une erreur
sociale en revanche nous devons tout
faire pour que chacun même lorsqu'il est
au chômage est une activité de
remplacement de substitution partielle
peut-être et que cette activité soit
rémunéré merci merci alain duhamel
alors avant de retourner à -cp monsieur
miss d'état quelques éléments
d'information sur ce que pensent les
français la façon de fusion suivi ce que
vous avez dit puisqu'au fond les a
interrogés sur les propositions vous
faisiez alors on va remonter le temps en
prime des questions en ce sens inverse
question souhaitez vous que les grands
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
déclare leur candidature rapidement
c'est à dire avant le début février fin
janvier début février
et là vous êtes très suivis 59 % pour
rapidement plus tard c'est à dire après
la d'après février
30 % sans opinion 11% deuxième question
qui a été posée par télé questionnaire
par la sofres
jacques chirac at il eu raison ou tort
de jouer le jeu de la cohabitation
là aussi vous allez certaines lois de
satisfaits raison 66% tort 12 % sans
opinion
22 % et enfin troisième question qui
était en fait la première la crise
boursière et financière aura-t-elle sur
votre vote à l'élection présidentielle
une influence grande faible ou sans
opinion
grande affluence grande influence sur le
vote 25% faible affluence 64 % sans
opinion
11% donc ça se passe de commentaire sur
la vague de paraphraser ce qu'il est
déjà de dire bien
alors svp d'autres questions sur hui
monsieur le ministre monsieur minutes
j'ai ici quelques questions très
concrètes
ma facture de téléphone dit ce
téléspectateur a augmenté de 18 6% le
taux de tva ou et la baisse de 7%
annoncé dans les journaux il faut
prévenir que baisser longuet n'est pas
là aujourd'hui exceptionnellement ne
nous répondait oui écouter jean et la
baisse de 7% de quoi exactement je
demande pardon mais j'ai pas très bien
compris la question la best 700 de quoi
les journaux ont annoncé une baisse de
7% des communications internes au
valjoly
c'est à voir le jeu par le jeu de mots
bien fait sur deux sujets la durée
d'attention ce sont deux choses
différentes il y a effectivement une
baisse de l'ensemble un certain nombre
de communication il ya d'autre part
l'application de la tva aux
télécommunications
ce qui permet ce qui permet aux
entreprises de la déduire et ce qui
constitue pour elle d'abord une mesure
qui les met à égalité avec les autres
entreprises en europe et 2ème en
allègement de leurs charges
autre question oui on lit on lit et que
la hausse du dollar est mauvais pour
l'économie française que la baisse du
dollar est mauvais pour l'économie
française
où est la vérité une question de
proportion et entre les deux la vérité
entre les deux une hausse excessive du
dollar alors que nous payons d'ailleurs
toutes nos importations dollars est
évidemment un facteur de renchérissement
de considérables
pour la vie dans notre pays et une
baisse excessive du dollar a pour
résultat de rendre la compétition pour
nos entreprises françaises et européenne
extraordinairement difficile et
actuellement je n'hésite pas à dire que
c'est peut-être l'une des plus graves
menaces qui pèsent sur l'europe sur
l'europe de l'ouest que cette
concurrence que peuvent faire les
produits non seulement américain mais de
l'ensemble des pays du monde rattaché au
dollar concurrence accrue du fait de la
baisse du dollar
quel est le juste prix du dollar coûtait
c'est difficile pour un ministre des
finances de le dire le juste prix serait
me semble-t-il supérieur au prix actuel
pour rappel quand même c'est quoi 5,55
c'est ça exactement
autre question oui pourquoi la france
dépense tel tant d'argent à aider des
pays étrangers notamment en afrique
alors qu'il y a tant de pauvres dans
notre propre et or je vais vous répondre
d'abord il ya beaucoup de pauvres dans
ces pays là aussi ce sont des pays que
nous avons conduits à la civilisation
celle etc afin que nous avons administré
nous avons versé une responsabilité
morale et nous ne pouvons pas l'oublier
en second lieu ce sont des pays qui en
toute circonstance manifeste avec la
france une solidarité morale politique
diplomatique qui a également de grands
avantages pour notre pays et enfin ce
sont des pays qui réserve à nos
industries à nos entreprises à nos
exportations
une très grande place je dirais donc que
c'est à la fois une nécessité économique
est un devoir moral bien
autre question oui alors que les
restaurants du coeur connaissent des
difficultés trouvez vous normal que le
directeur de la banque de france touche
à son départ 160 millions de centimes a
coûté la vie de la des entreprises est
effectivement plein de cas dans lequel
les dirigeants ou d'ailleurs d'autres
que les dirigeants il s'agit aussi
parfois des niveaux autres touchent des
indemnités lorsqu'ils quittent leurs
fonctions
on voit ça partout
c'est une question de proportions je
n'ai pas intervenir dans ce genre de
d'appréciation ni de jugement
quant aux restaurants du coeur ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je trouve qu'il
s'agit d'une initiative tout à fait
heureuse tout à fait généreuse qui
méritent d'être encouragés que la loi
que j'ai fait voter sur le mécénat
encouragera mais je voudrais quand même
rappeler qu'il a fallu attendre les
années récentes pour que la pauvreté
fille sa réapparition dans notre pays et
randy nes et rendent nécessaire et
restaurants du coeur que vous parlez de
ces dernières années c'est bien entendu
les années vous adversaires politiques
étaient au pouvoir
exactement bien une dernière question
jean louis ou une question politique
maintenant existe-t-il pour vous des
personnes de valeur au parti socialiste
avec lesquels vous pourriez gouverner
comme le pense monsieur bart je ne sais
pas si monsieur barnes ans il existe
sûrement des personnes de valeur au
parti socialiste s'en est même rencontré
quelques-unes
quant à gouverner c'est une toute autre
affaire
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire que ceux
qui comptaient dans une élection c'était
de proposer au pays une vision claire un
objectif clair et qu'il fallait que
chacun se détermine par rapport à cet
objectif
si tel ou tel membre d'un parti ou parti
pris globalement ce rallye à cet
objectif librement fixé par l'homme qui
le fait approuver par le pays
alors on peut en tirer les conséquences
bien alors jean boissonnat jambes à cela
directeur du groupe expansion pour 20
minutes
[Musique]
c'est à dire bonsoir on a déjà su gérer
la plupart des questions que je devais
vous posez ce qui m'évite d'avoir à
faire oeuvre d'imagination et la
première concerne naturellement cette
crise boursière et je voudrais vous
demander est-ce que vous avez été
complètement surpris par ce qui s'est
passé dans les marchés financiers
mondiaux au mois d'octobre dernier
ou est ce qu'il y avait pour vous
quelques signes annonciateurs dans le
déroulement de la vie des bourses pas
simplement de la bourse française depuis
quelques mois j'ai été très largement
surpris je ne suis pas de ceux qui
prédisent le passé
cela étant il est bien vrai que les les
bourses avaient beaucoup augmenté depuis
plusieurs années et probablement alors
qu'elle était sous-évalué il ya quatre
ou cinq ans etait-elle surévalué mais
enfin cela aurait plus corriger sans
drame si je puis dire ce qui a été
véritablement le détonateur on ne le
répétera jamais assez c'est l'inquiétude
née des fluctuations monétaires et des
désordres monétaires c'est la source des
maux dont souffrent l'occident alors sur
le point précis que vous venez d'évoquer
c'est à dire que ça pouvait la
correction vous verrez c'est inévitable
mais elle aurait pu se passer sans drame
comment se fait-il si vous aviez
l'intuition qu'une correction était
possible que vous ayez encore poussé le
mouvement de privatisation à la rentrée
de septembre
je dirais qu'elles étaient dues je me
doutais que vous alliez en venir à cette
question là j'ai dit qu'elle était
souhaitable j'ai pas dit qu'elle était
possible mais c'est ce qu'il me semble
du moins j'espère que j'ai un bon
souvenir de ce que je viens de dire il
ya une minute
en second lieu monsieur boissonnat je
suis désolé de vous contredire mais je
n'ai pas poussé le mouvement de
privatisation mois de septembre pas du
tout pas du tout il y a eu une
privatisation à la fin juin au début de
juillet je croise été celle de tf2 m'a
semblé que c'était la dernière avant
l'été et j'ai dit que les choses
reprendre à l'automne avec la
privatisation de suez qui a pas eu d'
accélération du mouvement contrairement
à ce que je lis parfois vous en aviez
fait beaucoup prêts auparavant à mais ça
c'est une autre affaire vous m'a dit que
j'avais accélérés à parti
en septembre vous n'êtes jamais fait un
certain nombre auparavant je vais faire
ajouter quelque chose à quelque chose
qui était déjà important qui était déjà
important mais qui n'a nullement été un
facteur d'aggravation de la crise vous
savez très bien pourquoi d'ailleurs vous
savez même mieux que moi mais j'ai pas
dit que c'était ça qui avaient aggravé
la crise vous le savez même mieux que
moi simplement je crois que dès lors
qu'il y avait en faveur des
privatisations un courant est d'ailleurs
un courant qui s'est maintenue dans une
large mesure et j'en vois la preuve
d'une part dans la stabilité
beaucoup plus grande qu'ailleurs des
petits porteurs qu'il va falloir à tout
prix d'ailleurs associé mieux à la
gestion de leur entreprise des
entreprises je souhaite que les
dirigeants d'entreprises fasse preuve de
toute ouverture d'esprit de toute
l'imagination nécessaire et désirable et
je crois donc que ce mouvement de
privatisation été portée à ce moment là
alors il s'y est fait qu'a eu la crise
vous avez observé que depuis la crise je
les suspendus allez-vous le reprendre je
m'interroge je m'interroge
si je le reprends je le ferai en premier
lieu en faveur d'une entreprise telle
que matra ce qu'elle forme parce que
parce que je considère que matra la
sphère était engagé là la décision était
prise les études avaient été faites et
parce qu'il s'agit pour matraquer
d'ailleurs une affaire de beaucoup moins
grande ampleur il s'agit de mener à bon
terme une entreprise de comment vous
dire de regroupement européen qui est
essentiel pour son avenir industriel
mais je suis en train d'y réfléchir et
de voir sous quelle forme éventuellement
ça pourrait être prise m'étais imaginé
qu'on pourrait tenter de le faire sous
forme d'obligations convertibles
convertibles et puis à la réflexion ça
présente des inconvénients techniques
cela étant l'offre sur le marché de
matra c'est une chose de relativement
faible importance 4 à 500 ou 600
millions de francs peut-être ça n'a rien
à voir avec les ordres de grandeurs
antérieur
vous pourriez le faire au mois de
janvier ah si je me décide il faudra que
ça ait lieu fin janvier début février
et les grandes compagnies d'assurances
auquel vous aviez pensé
j'ai toujours dit que j'étais très
pragmatique dans cette affaire et que je
me laisser guider par les circonstances
c'est l'opportunité des choses
vous avez observé que la bourse est
meilleure depuis deux jours mais je ne
me contente pas deux jours quand il
observé que les changes sont meilleurs
également depuis quelques jours alors
qu'on nous avait prédit je le rappelle
en passant qu'aussitôt la fin des fêtes
l'ouverture du mois de janvier ce serait
le drame général vous voyez qu'il n'en
est rien mais enfin il faut davantage
pour se faire une opinion il faut
surtout sentir chez tous une vraie
volonté de défendre les parités
monétaires à leur niveau actuel car s'il
n'ya pas cette volonté c'est parité ne
pourront pas résister et si elles ne
peuvent pas résister la bourse ne ne
pourra pas non et donc je ne serai pas
dans mon rôle de ministre des finances
qui d'abord le défenseur de l'epargne si
je n'en tenait pas compte
vous avez révélé dans une déclaration à
la tribune au début de la semaine qu'il
y avait un accord secret qui venait
compléter les dispositions rendu public
entre les sept grands pays
industrialisés pour faire en sorte que
les variations de change ne soit pas
absurde et aujourd'hui du japon sont
venues des précisions sur le
fonctionnement de cet accord secret
disant qu ils concernaient
principalement les états unis le japon
et l'allemagne
est ce à dire que nous ne serions pas
partie prenante et que peut-on dire de
plus sur le mécanisme mis en place
je voudrais pas il s'agit d'un accord
secret vous venez de le dire je me suis
déjà laissé aller pour la tribune ce que
peut être une excuse à vos yeux à
quelques indiscrétions devrait pas aller
beaucoup plus loin
haas a eu des effets bla et 10 vous-même
le dollar était redressé à j'ai pas dit
que c'était à cause de ça
enfin si vous le jugez j'en suis heureux
quel constat
je voudrais vous rassurer nous ne sommes
pas en dehors de cet accord pas du tout
en dehors savez achetant des dollars en
ce moment ça veut dire que chacun des
pays a pris des engagements et que ces
engagements doivent être tenus mais je
voudrais aller plus loin si vous niez
autorisé monsieur boissonnat sait très
bien ce que l'on fait on estime que le
monde a besoin de la stabilité monétaire
on a raison il faut que ceux qui nous
écoutent comprennent ce dont il s'agit
partout dans le monde les transactions
sont calculés en dollars
s'il ya quatre ans le dollar vaut 10
francs et puis si aujourd'hui vos seins
francs 50
et puis si on ne sait pas ce qu'il
faudra demain comment voulez vous qu'un
entrepreneur français allemand anglais
japonais investissent achètent vendent
passent des contrats c'est impossible
donc nous avons un absolu besoin de la
stabilité des monnaies pour développer
le commerce international et la
croissance
mais comment est encore il suffit non je
ne le crois pas je ne crois pas cet
accord prend acte du fait que nous
sommes dans un régime de change flottant
est dans un régime de change flottant
dans lequel la valeur des monnaies monte
ou baisse selon des événements
politiques économiques ou financiers il
essaie d'organiser ce flottement mais on
a bien vu que c'est insuffisant
vous avez dit dans une dans la même
déclaration d'ailleurs que vous
souhaitiez un système monétaire il y ait
des automatismes et des sanctions
absolue vous pouvez préciser cette
pensée si votre pensée sur ce point
précis automatique et sens que si c'est
difficile c'est difficile mais journée
d'hier en deux mots la chose suivante
nous avions jusqu'en 1971 un système
dans lequel les changes était disons que
c'était un système stable il y avait des
dévaluations la france a dévalué
notamment plusieurs fois depuis 1945
mais c'était un système qui avait ses
automatismes et qui avait ses sens et le
dollar était rattaché alors le dollar
était rattaché à vous le souhaitez
toujours qu'il redevienne rattaché alors
je ne sais pas si c'est possible mais il
faudrait trouver un instrument de
référence qui ne soit pas l'une des
monnaies à mon avis non quoi d'autre
qu'elle a et bien écoutez on peut y
réfléchir peut-être c'est justement un
mois un sujet de réflexion important je
crois en ce qui me concerne que nous
vivons la fin de la période des changes
flottants et je crois qu'il est temps de
revenir à un système
je le répète aussi automatiques et aussi
contraignant que possible et c'est ce
que je souhaiterais que les ministres
des finances des grands pays
industrialisés discute maintenant entre
temps le système européen c'est pas un
système de change flottant non mais ce
n'est pas non plus un système rattaché
alors non est ce que ça vous paraît un
exemple ce qu'il faudrait faire à
l'échelle mondiale
et est-ce que tel qu'il fonctionne le
système européen vous convient non pas
tout à fait pourquoi parce que je trouve
qu'il n'est pas très égalitaire d'abord
il n'est pas complet il n'ya parmi les
grandes monnaies que le dhj le mark et
le franc qui soit vraiment membre à part
entière les autres ont tous les régimes
un peu particulier il faudrait donc que
toutes les grandes monnaies y compris la
lire et la livre sterling
ils fussent rattaché c'est le premier
point il fonde en second lieu que les
obligations soient de même nature pour
tous ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
je veux pas entrer dans le détail de la
technique c'est très compliqué je trouve
qu'il faudrait autrement dit que la
coopération monétaire entre les grands
pays européens soit mieux organisé
qu'elle ne l'est de façon plus solidaire
et enfin pour aller vite et résumé je
trouve que le moment est venu là aussi
d'examiner la possibilité de créer une
banque centrale européenne qui gérerait
une monnaie commune qui pourrait être
l'équipe par exemple ça pose beaucoup de
questions techniques mais je me propose
d'en saisir mes collègues dans les jours
qui viennent
et de demander qu'on en discute ensemble
maintenant mais dans un tel système est
ce que le franc n'est pas trop
étroitement attachés aux marques un
moment l'économie allemande semble
considérer que la croissance qu'elle
connaît c'est à dire pas très rapide
suffit dans un pays où la population
n'augmente pas mais n'aime diminue vous
avez tout à fait raison et c'est bien
pourquoi je souhaite que le système
monétaire européen ne se réduisent pas
comme c'est le cas actuellement au
dialogue franco-allemand
mais qu'il s'étende à l'ensemble des
grandes monnaies européennes et selon
des règles plus juste car dans l'état
actuel des choses les interventions des
banques centrales ne sont pas
équitablement
répartie vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que 1 de notre grand problème c'est que
nous perdions des parts de marché en
effet pour la première fois en 1987 pour
la première fois depuis 1969
sir depuis bien longtemps les échanges
de produits industriels entre la france
et l'étranger ont été déficitaires
on n'avait jamais vu ça depuis 1969 donc
vous êtes préoccupé par ce sujet et vous
avez dit une des raisons pour lesquelles
les entreprises françaises ont fait des
performances qui n'était pas très
satisfaisante c'est peut-être qu'elle
était trop chargé et que d'une manière
générale il y avait des charges trop
lourdes en france et vous avez attachez
votre politique un allègement des
charges charge des impôts et charges de
l'ensemble des prélèvements sur les
individus c'est à dire impôts
cotisations sociales quand on regarde
les chiffres qui sont publiés par vos
services
on observe que l'allègement de ses
charges en produit par rapport aux
revenus de chacun d'entre nous ne se
manifeste pas qu autrement dit les rues
quelque part quelqu'un qui aurait repris
ce que vous avez consentis comme
allègements alors comment souhaitez-vous
faire dans l'avenir pour y parvenir
compte tenu de ce résultat un peu
décevant j'imagine à vos propres yeux
oui alors écoutez il faut que les choses
soient bien claires si vous le voulez
bien parce que il y a beaucoup de
confusion dans ce débat qu'avons nous
fait depuis deux ans alain juppé et moi
même nous avons réduit le déficit d'à
peu près une quarantaine de milliards et
j'aurai l'occasion lorsque l'on présente
pas l'exécution du budget 1987 pour dire
que contrairement à ce que beaucoup
avait dit où quelques-uns plus tôt ce
budget est très bien exécuté et même
mieux que prévu
ce sera une très bonne surprise pour
notre économie
donc il y à une quarantaine de milliards
de baisse du déficit et 70 milliards de
baisse d'un pour à peu près et au regard
il y à une augmentation des cotisations
sociales de l'ordre d'une trentaine de
milliards ce sont les ordres de
grandeurs je crois que je ne suis pas
d'inexactitudes marquantes donc 40
milliards de baisse du déficit de l'état
70 milliards de baisses d impôts de
l'état 30 milliards d'augmentation des
cotisations sociales contenues
de la situation des régimes de sécurité
sociale qui est dans une large mesure la
conséquence du chômage bien vous êtes
trop averti monsieur boissonnat pour ne
pas savoir que le niveau des
prélèvements dans une société varie
selon que le déficit existe ou n'existe
pas autrement dit lorsque vous avez un
déficit de sens et que vous prélevez 200
c'est très différent si vous continuez à
prélever des 2 200 mais que le déficit
est plus de 80 90 ça change les choses
notamment pour le marché financier et
d'autre part il serrera j'observe si
vous le permettez qu'en regardant les
chiffres de près que vous continuez
d'alourdir la dette de l'état légèrement
mais les un peu 1988 mais c'est
inévitable
c'est inévitable parce qu'il ya du
déficit budgétaire fait ça donc
donc tout autant mais tout non mais ça
prouve combien il est indispensable de
réduire le déficit budgétaire je sais
que depuis la crise boursière et
monétaires il est redevenu à la mode de
dire vous avez une marge de manoeuvre
fait du déficit et tout ira très bien
qu'est ce que ça veut dire faire du
déficit ça veut dire emprunter comme
vous venez de le dire très justement ça
veut dire payer des charges d'intérêt et
ça veut dire alourdir le poids de ce qui
pèsera sur les générations futures donc
il est impératif que nous redescendions
à un niveau de déficit qui ne devrait
pas dépasser 60 à 70 milliards de francs
nous sommes à 115
j'ai demandé qu'on commence à regarder
ce que pourrait être le budget 89 après
tout c'est dans ma responsabilité encore
pour quatre mois et j'ai fixé comme
orientation de retenir un chiffre de
déficit de l'ordre de 100 milliards donc
encore une réduction
il faut qu'en trois ou quatre ans nous
arrivions à réduire le déficit
suffisamment pour que la dette de l'état
de s'augmenter oui mais j'observe que
vous vous inquiétez du déficit de l'état
en 1989 mais pas du déficit de la
sécurité sociale en 1988
aucune disposition n'a été prise pour
faire face aux prévisions de 20
milliards de francs de déficit en 1988
du régime d'assurance vieillesse
alors regardons les choses si vous
voulez bien et tout ce que vous dites
est tout à fait juste mais regardons les
choses on nous avait dit il y aura 40
milliards de déficit dans le régime
général de sécurité sociale
puis on nous a dit on aura 33 puis on a
10 27
actuellement l'état 19 saviez vous
attendez qu'on nous dise 0 n'ont séduit
que l'on ne nous dira pas 0 on ne nous
dira pas érosion le dis je ne le croirai
quand je crois que le régime d'assurance
maladie le régime d'accidents du travail
le régime familial sont tirés d'affaires
et sont équilibrés c'est déjà beaucoup à
trois risques sur quatre qui sont
équilibrées
il en reste d'équilibrer la vieillesse
commence c'est la vieillesse qu'il ya un
déséquilibre de l'ordre d'une vingtaine
de milliards de francs
c'est la conséquence de l'allongement de
la durée de la vie de l'abaissement de
l'âge de la retraite et de toute une
série de facteurs de cet ordre là et du
chômage aussi qui diminue le nombre de
ceux qui cotisent alors que faut-il
faire
je n'ai pas souhaité pour ce qui me
concerne et d'ailleurs chacun le sait je
n'ai pas souhaité que l'on prenne des
décisions trop rapide en la matière il y
avait un projet précis de votre collègue
ministère du travail pour instituer un
prélèvement proportionnel sur l'ensemble
des revenus se poser ou enfin y avait
des projets de ce sens là dans ce sens
là je n'ai pas souhaité parce que c'est
un vrai problème pour notre société
nous allons vivre de plus en plus vieux
avec une durée d'étude de scolarité de
plus en plus long grâce au ciel et donc
ceux qui vont travailler vont
représenter une part de plus en plus
petit par rapport à ceux qui ne
travaillent pas actuellement il ya 55
millions de français et 21 millions
d'actifs je crois ou 22 bien il faut
donc que ces 22 millions d'actifs qui
sont les deux cinquièmes paix à la fois
l'éducation des enfants et des
adolescents et des jeunes et leur
instruction et leur formation
ep les retraites ça veut dire que vous
souhaitez un relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite
non écoutez je souhaite commander là et
qu'on choisisse entre deux attitudes ou
bien on maintient toutes les retraites
au niveau actuel et ça veut dire qu'on
n'évitera pas soit une hausse des
cotisations soit un élève un relèvement
de l'âge de la retraite ou bien on ne
veut pas augmenter les cotisations et on
ne veut pas non plus relevé l'âge de la
retraite et on ne pourra pas prêt payer
les retraites au même niveau
qu'aujourd'hui ça mérite je vous assure
un vrai débat avant la présidentielle ou
bien avant et pendant et à mon avis
c'est une décision qui ne doit pas être
comment vous dire un peu influencé par
l'élection présidentielle c'est un
problème vraiment pour le coup un
problème de société qui est pas un
problème de droite ou de gauche n'est ce
pas le choix que je viens de dire c'est
un vrai choix enfin 13 mètres près votre
votre inclination actuelle serait
pourquoi relever l'âge de la retraite
réduire la retraite ou relever les
cotisations puisque c'est bien les trois
donné que vous nous avez mis entre les
mains
mon inclination actuelle je parle à
titre personnel ne se passait pas du
tout le projet du gouvernement je parle
à titre personnel mon inclination
actuelle serait de maintenir les
retraites à leur niveau actuel est de
relever l'âge de la retraite
et d'ailleurs c'est pour cela que j'ai
fait passer et voté un projet sur le
plan d'epargne en vue de la retraite qui
prévoit une incitation fiscale
importante pour inciter les français à
prendre leur retraite
un peu plus tard un an deux ans trois
ans [ __ ] c'est même un choix politique
puisque c'est au fond la gauche qui
avait abaissé l'âge de la retraite et
que les libéraux proposent c'est un
choix politique je dirais que c'est au
delà et en dehors de la politique c'est
une dirais que c'est une nécessité
sociale drop vraiment que le problème de
la retraite se pose dans les termes dans
lesquels je viens de le poser est
vraiment j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on mette
la politique les discussions polémique
en dehors de tout cela ça mérite qu'on
regarde la chose de près parmi vos
grands projets il y a le marché unique
européen au début de 1993
est un des éléments réalisation du
marché unique c'est l'uniformisation ou
du moins le rapprochement des taux de
tva entre les grands pays
il se trouve que la france a le taux de
tva le plus élevé en moyenne par rapport
à ses voisins la logique voudrait donc
conformément à votre politique que vous
réduisiez d'ailleurs vous l'avez fait
pour l'automobile récemment et pour
quelques autres produits que vous
réduisiez le taux de tva en france si on
devait aligner le taux français de tva
sur celui de la moyenne de nos voisins
cela vous faire perdre 80 milliards de
francs de recettes fiscales
alors hein est-ce que c'est cela que
vous souhaitez faire et à ce moment-là 2
que reste-t-il de disponible pour abc
d'autres impôts peut-on même faire ça
sans relever d'autres impôts je vous
répondrai que l'on ne va pas baisser les
impôts indéfiniment dans toutes les
directions
nous avions une situation qui était une
situation anormale à laquelle il fallait
porter remède ça n'est pas d'ailleurs
encore tout à fait fini mais il viendra
au moment où bien entendu il faudra que
les impôts permettent à la collectivité
de payer les dépenses collectives
l'idée que je me fais des choses est la
suivante j'ai proposé comme vous le
savez un plan triennal diminuer le
déficit budgétaire de 45 milliards en
trois ans et diminuer les impôts de 45
milliards en trois ans les trois années
89 90 91 1 seulement la tva alors alors
je pense que ça devrait être le
principal et ensuite il y aura 92 93
bien entendu et les années qui suivront
je pense que le principal de notre
effort devrait être maintenant consacrer
à la baisse de la tva mais j'aurais vous
dire que si nous attendons pour entrer
de plain pied dans l'europe d'avoir en
tout dans tous les domaines fiscaux
juridiques économiques les mêmes statuts
les mêmes règles nous ne ferons jamais
l'heure on pense souvent l'exemple des
états unis
vous le connaissez mieux que moi vous
savez très bien que les états américains
les états de l'union n'ont pas tous la
même fiscalité
ici la peau direct et plus élevé la
l'impôt indirect est plus élevé ou c'est
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui les d'avant
taj dans un troisième état et bien je
crois qu'il faudra faire l'europe tout
de même et puis on sent arrangera de ses
divergences et ses difficultés
ça prendra peut-être plus de quatre ou
cinq ans mais il faudra tout de même le
faire
dernier point les taux d'intérêt c'est
une de nos grandes préoccupations les
taux d'intérêt français sont très élevés
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs le franc n'a pas trop de
soucis vis-à-vis du marque
ils sont probablement trop élevée vous
l'avez dit vous-même vous avez fait un
tout petit geste récemment
d'intervention sur les marchés pour
montrer le sens que vous vouliez donner
à la baisse des taux d'intérêt est ce
que cela signifie que vous allez aussi
baisser les taux d'intérêt sur ce que
l'on peut appeler les taux administrés
et notamment les taux sur les livrets de
caisse d'epargne il n'en est pas
question pour le moment c'est pas dans
mes intentions
je note quand même que les taux
d'intérêt sont chez nous plus faible que
dans trois des sept pays industrialisés
je pense notamment à l'italie à la
grande bretagne mais pas beaucoup plus
faible à peine plus faible et je
reconnais que nous les taux sont élevés
dans notre pays mais ils sont élevés
plus en terme de taux réels qu'en termes
de taux nominal comme vous le savez oui
mais les taux réels c'est bien ce qu'on
paye réel marc exactement vous avez tout
à fait raison
dernière question purement politique si
françois henry me le permet je sais
c'est ce à dessein que vous ne m'avez
pas parler du bilan du gouvernement au
nom parce que bien sûr il est à ces
bilans et appareils à travers toutes les
toutes vos réponses très bien puisque
vous avez eu chaque fois l'occasion de
ravel et de l'étudiant vous avez baissé
les impose ravi de vous voir si bien
édifié comme disait madame pernel à 10
ans si bien informé
je suis frappé par votre comportement
notamment depuis le début de l'émission
et d'une manière plus générale l'extrême
attention que vous portez à
protéger et à préparer la candidature du
premier ministre à l'élection
présidentielle si vous permettez je suis
une observation toute personnelle que je
veux vous exprimer vous y répondre et ou
non d'ailleurs je me demande parfois si
par cette manière de protéger le premier
ministre est apparaître comme étant
complètement à côté de lui pour le
soutenir dans cette épreuve sans le
vouloir du tout vous ne risquez pas de
le desservir en donnant l'impression que
cet homme là ce candidat là a besoin
plus que d'autres dettes chaperonné par
des hommes d'expérience aurait coûté
alors là pour le coup je vois pas du
tout les choses comme ça
d'abord le prix est un nul besoin d'être
protégé et après tout vous pourriez
tenir le même propos à n'importe lequel
de vos invités qui se dit favorable à la
candidature de l'un des candidats
pour je vais pas citer de noms enfin on
pourrait en citer quelques-uns
alors je ne vois pas vous pourriez tenir
je le répète le même propos à chacun le
premier a nul besoin d'être protégé ça
être que leurs supporters n'ont pas
votre personnalité au couteau ils ont
d'autres raisons de des personnalités
tout à fait remarquable rassurez vous
tout à fait remarquable les concurrents
du premier ministre ne sont pas mal doté
non plus en ce qui concerne leur
entourage ou v ne vous faites aucun
souci pour eux dans ces conditions je ne
comment voulez vous que je réponde à la
question que vous me dites si j'en étais
très bien vous ne puissiez ne passerait
pas merci merci jean boissonnat alors
avant de retourner à -cp toujours les
questions les réponses étaient les
questionnaires avez vous le sentiment
que depuis deux ans par rapport à ses
principaux concurrents l'économie
française a tendance à rattraper son
retard à l'aggraver
sans opinion alors rattraper son retard
38% des gens pensent que nous rattrapons
notre retard et 43% vous le voyez quel
lagrave la bouteille et abriel gros
m'interroge sur le bilan peut-être que
ça aurait été différente
en vous écoutant tout répondra beau
senna duhamel sûr
justement les retards de l'économie
française sont l'adaptation de l'outil
de production
finalement il ya une question qui se
pose la question de l'investissement n'a
pas parlé du tout facile toi ô on
modernise pas assez nos installations si
on perd des parts chez des parts de
marché c'est parce qu'on modernise pas
d'installation bon vous avez énuméré
toutes les raisons pour lesquelles
c'était difficile de modifier les taux
d'intérêts l'argent richert actuellement
est ce que est ce que comme les
industriels vous le demande vous vous
leur accorderait quelque chose qui
prendrait la forme soit d'une aide à
l'investissement vous avez dit non je
sais déjà à la proposition de monsieur
bart soit d'une réduction de l'impôt sur
les sociétés vous avez expliqué tout à
l'heure qu'il est proposé d' harmoniser
les fiscalités pour faire le même
ensemble mais les américains sont à
l'impôt sur les sociétés à 34 %
l'allemagne je crois il vient et nous on
est toujours on était à 50 vous êtes
descendus à 44 on a toujours en tête
lille 2 et 42 pardonnez moi on a
toujours imposé sur les sociétés plus
élevé que non c'est vrai mais comme vous
le disiez à l'instant monsieur de virieu
nous étions à 50% sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés nous sommes maintenant à 42% et
nous avons également abaissé la taxe
professionnelle le résultat c'est que
l'investissement en france en 1986 et
1987 a pour la première fois depuis de
nombreuses années était parmi les
meilleurs sinon même selon certains
instituts le meilleur de tous les grands
pays industrialisés l'investissement
aura cru dans le secteur concurrentiel
de 10% en 1986 et en 1987 alors qu'il
avait décru dans les quatre années
antérieures et que dans les années
encore antérieur
ils avaient crû moins que la moyenne des
investissements des pays industrialisés
donc l'investissement a redémarré dans
notre pays je suis convaincu ans je suis
convaincu que c'est grâce aux libertés
nouvelles que nous avons donné aux
entreprises liberté des changes des
crédits et des prix avec un plein succès
je me permets de le dire qui aurait
pensé que la liberté des prix ce serait
accompagnée d'une inflation de l'ordre
de 3% cette année 3,2 3,2 le jour où
nous aurons les statistiques de décembre
1,2 sans doute et dans ces conditions
nous avons pris les mesures nécessaires
et les industriels lorsqu'on les
interroge et qu'on leur dit qu'est ce
que vous préférez la baisse des impôts
l'aide fiscale à la
this man et bien ils répondent de façon
très majoritaire nous préférons la
baisse des impôts et c'est dans ce sens
que je crois il faut continuer cela
étant il faut pas faire preuve d'esprit
dogmatique et je voudrais pas que cette
affaire d'être six cas l'investissement
devienne une sorte de de querelles
théologiques à l'intérieur de la
majorité d'ailleurs sur les sociétés
répression de la montée dans l'élite et
moi d'abord répondre de façon un peu
absurde et c'est pourquoi j'ai pris en
matière d'amortissement qui est une aide
à l'investissement une aide fiscale j'ai
pris un certain nombre de mesures depuis
deux mois
quant à l'impôt sur les sociétés je
disais tout à l'heure monsieur bré sauna
que l'essentiel de notre effort pour
l'avenir devait être un effort de baisse
de la tva mais je pense qu'il ya
également qu'il serait souhaitable que
l'impôt sur les sociétés descendu au
dessous de 40% bien alors un petit
retour sur la question des
privatisations l'opinion l'opinion des
français sur la poursuite à vous avez
appelé par l'exemple cela de l'avenir
des privatisations sur la poursuite
souhaitez vous que le programme de
privatisations reprenne a demandé la
sofres qu'il reprenne avant l'élection
présidentielle 17 % seulement des gens
après l'élection présidentielle 21% et
or là c'est un peu la surprise ou qu'il
soit définitivement arrêtée en son état
actuel 39% un commentaire si ça fait
trente huit pour 39 contre si j'ai bien
compté
oui si on veut effectivement compassion
sommeil l'arithmétique n'offrent pas la
place à la fantaisie 21 puisque 17 ça
fait 38 via ses archives qui vous
satisfait svp d'autres questions mais
monsieur le ministre
contrairement à ce qui se passait sous
la gauche comment se fait-il qu'avec la
baisse du dollar le prix de l'essence ne
diminue plus en proportion à le prix
baisse du dollar et la baisse et la
région du bas rhin qui est elle
le prix du bar et le prix de l'essence a
diminué à la pompe alors en proportion
peut en discuter il faut bien dire il
est vrai que les entreprises pétrolières
ont une certaine tendance à ne pas faire
de zèle en matière de traduction de la
baisse du dollar et des jeux les incite
oui je les aide mais elles ont de gros
frais en matière de raffinage faut être
juste et se mettre à leur place aussi le
raffinage en france coûte très cher mais
il est bien vrai que il m'arrive de
penser et de dire que la traduction de
la baisse du pétrole calculé en dollars
sur le prix à la pompe n'est pas assez
rapide ni assez aussi complète qu'elle
le devrait bien jean lui le scène
pourquoi dans un régime libéral la
majorité des membres des cabinets
ministériels ou des personnalités
nommées à la tête des entreprises
publiques sont ils issus de la fonction
publique des entreprises
ça c'est une question effectivement que
nous n'avons jamais su aucun
gouvernement quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs
résoudre convenablement d'accès gêne
moins que d'autres
il y en a que ça gêne moins que d'autres
moi je suis un peu un peu gêné de ne pas
l'avoir bien résolue j'aurai beaucoup
souhaité élargir effectivement l'horizon
des choix j'avais même envisagé de faire
appel à ce qu'on appelle maintenant d'un
vilain mot d'ailleurs un cabinet de
chasseurs de têtes qui je ne les ai pas
fait j'étais pris par le temps je crois
qu'effectivement il faut que nous
sortions d'un système dans lequel il y à
une élite administrative plein de vertus
de valeur et de talent sahara sans dire
mais qui se voit réserver tous les
postes à la tête des ministères et des
entreprises publiques
c'est vrai et nous n'avons pas fait
assez pour cela c'est vrai bien et bien
albert du roy pour 20 minutes
bonsoir monsieur
elles font pour vous êtes vous être
agréable vous à vous donner l'occasion
de satisfaire un souhait que vous avez
exprimées par cette émission et
commencez par vous demander au début
d'émission vous avez indiqué que vous
auriez sans doute l'occasion de revenir
sur les différences des points précis de
différence entre raymond barre et
jacques chirac a je ne les ai pas dit
spontanément en répondant à une question
en répondant à une question de monsieur
duhamel
alors je voudrais savoir un peu quel
point précis par exemple coûté vraiment
à dire le vrai et j'ai dit que je
penserais que j'aurai l'occasion parce
que je ne doutais que vous me poseriez
la question mais à dire l'entrée des
électeurs de la majorité se posent aux
halles l'un plutôt que l'eau qu'ils ont
tout à fait raison de se la poser ils
ont tout à fait raison s'imposer sur le
plan technique je pense et je dirais sur
le plan politique générale la conception
de la société la conception de la vie en
société
très proche sinon identiques il y a bien
entendu des débats sur des points qui
sont des points relativement je dirais
pas secondaire mais d'un essentiel je
parlais de l'aide fiscale investissement
tout à l'heure il peut y avoir d'autres
débats du même type n'est ce pas vers
voyez un autre comme ça oui ou de celle
qui vous passe par était je n'en vois
pas énormément à dire le vrai m'enfin il
peut y en avoir d'autres
et mais nous attendrons pour cela de
voir ce que proposent chacun des
candidats c'est la raison pour laquelle
je souhaite que les candidats maintenant
se déclarer dise clairement devant le
pays ce qu'ils veulent faire
que monsieur chirac tease ce qu'il veut
faire que monsieur bart dise ce qu'il
veut faire et que monsieur mitterrand ou
monsieur rocha ou tout autre 10
la conception qu'ils ont encore du
socialisme
je crois que c'est un problème qui
mériteraient qu'on en discute à votre
avis dans le sondage auprès des patrons
dont parlait alain duhamel tout à
l'heure il apparaît que les patrons
préfèrent largement raymond barre à
jacques chirac comme setteur président
de la république
comment expliquez vous cette attitude
que vous ne partagez pas évidemment
comment voulez vous que je vous dire que
quand vous pourrez vous répondre n'est
ce pas je crois que vous travaillez
d'autres catégories professionnelles ou
sociales vous en trouverez même beaucoup
qui préfèrent jacques chirac à raymond
ah bon et puis voilà c'est tout l'art
est bon il n'y a pas d'autre explication
il n'y a pas d'explication qui me
paraissent rationnelle en tout cas parce
que la politique suivie depuis deux ans
a été pour le développement des
entreprises et pour le développement
notre économie et pour la libération de
notre économie et pour la diminution des
déficits la politique la plus dynamique
je me permets de le dic est la plus
efficace menée depuis de très nombreuses
années
est-ce que parmi les raisons qui en
dehors de beaucoup d'autres qui vous
font préférer jacques chirac à raymond
barre
est ce qu'il y à celle celle ci que
étant premier ministre aujourd'hui
jacques chirac élu président de la
république dès le 9 mai au matin
la france pourra être gouverné avec une
certaine continuité
autrement dit si dans le cas où je
serais raymond barre il n'y aurait pas
un
trou dans le gouvernement de la france
du temps perdu sa vie il y a plusieurs
candidats même s'ils sont pas déclarés
comme vous l'avez observé et chacun fait
son choix et préfère un candidat plutôt
qu'un autre
moi moi l'adhésion totale complète va à
jacques chirac
parce que c'est un homme qui est
courageux il a pris les risques de la
cohabitation qui aurait dit il ya deux
ans ce que raymond barre n'a pas fait
avait dit qu'il coûtait rien au mof
vraiment il faut pas faire une fixation
sur monsieur bah a parlé moi de temps à
autre de monsieur mitterrand de monsieur
rocard et vous en parlez alès lattes en
mieux jacques chirac en 1986 a pris les
risques de la cohabitation qui aurait
dit il ya deux ans que ça se passerait
comme ça c'est à dire finalement sans
heurt sans problème institutionnel grave
avec un gouvernement qui a pu qui a pu
mettre en oeuvre des réformes
importantes et obtenir des résultats
c'est un premier motif
le deuxième c'est qu'il a fait la preuve
que c'était un homme efficace et un
homme apte à diriger une équipe
gouvernement est prêt mais de vous
reposer ma question est ce qu'avec
d'autres que jacques chirac
il risque d'y avoir du temps perdu pour
le gouvernement de la france à partir de
l'élection de miss mais bon il y aura
trois semaines à un mois de perdu le
temps de l'élection c'est évident c'est
évident vous souhaitez parler de
françois mitterrand est-ce que depuis la
cohabitation depuis deux ans la fonction
présidentielle a été dévalué on ne croit
pas elle a été différente à un président
qui décide en dernier ressort de tous
dans tous les domaines
s'il le veut s'ils ne le veut pas il
laisse faire il a le pouvoir de décider
dès lors qui est le chef de la majorité
parlementaire le véritable chef à ce
principe de présidence et substituer à
un président qui a des pouvoirs
importants mais dans des domaines
dignité et qui utilise ses pouvoirs qui
sont davantage des pouvoirs d' influence
je dirais d'expression de sabotage de
conseil
c'est tout à fait ccc largement
différent toute la question est de
savoir si une fois qu'on aura mis fin
cette période de cohabitation ce que je
souhaite
car je n'ai jamais considéré que la
cohabitation était l'idéal c'est
toujours considéré que c'était une
transition inévitable
toute la question est de savoir si une
fois que l'on aura mis fin à cette
cohabitation il restera quelque chose de
cette expérience qui a vu un président
se tenir en dehors des choses et un
gouvernement et un chef de gouvernement
à agir avec davantage de liberté par
exemple la voix résidents de la
république ne pas exercer d'une façon
aussi total pour la commune la guerre la
totalité du pouvoir
oui c'est ce que je voulais dire toute
la question est là et vous le souhaitez
vous savez je crois que le bon équilibre
le bon équilibre je parle d'une période
dans laquelle il y aurait identité de
vues entre le président de la république
le premier ministre les gouvernements le
bon équilibre serait quelque chose qui
serait un peu intermédiaire entre la
situation actuelle et la situation de 7
ans c'est ça et a de ce point de vue
jacques chirac vous semble le meilleur
garant de ce nouvel équilibre plutôt
qu'un autre candidat que je ne citerai
pas pour ne pas vous agacer au ça ne
m'agace pas du tout écoutez je ne sais
pas ce que ferait d'autres candidats je
crois que jacques chirac en tout cas se
dit tout à fait résolus à préserver cet
équilibre et parce que ça fait partie de
sa conception des choses
en acceptant la cohabitation il lave ont
seulement pris un risque qu'il a assumée
mais il a également témoigné me semble
t'il qu'il états d'âme de rassemblement
qu'il est un homme qui essaie dans toute
la mesure du possible d'éviter des
déchirures inutile et des combats nous
n'avons que trop souffert de cette sorte
de deux guerres civiles verbale à
laquelle notre pays se laissent trop
souvent aller et je trouve que sur ce
plan là la cohabitation en effet si je
puis dire
morales et politiques et psychologiques
très importants là jacques chirac a
montré
qu'il était cet homme de rassemblement
et c'est une des raisons pour lequel mon
suffrage et mon soutien lui est
intégralement tech abordé un autre
problème qui est un problème très
concret qui intéresse beaucoup les gens
c'est celui de la fiscalité qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure vous disiez tout à
l'heure
l'arithmétique ne laisse pas la place à
la fantaisie alors est ce que vous êtes
en face de moi pour vous demander une
explication passe quelque chose que je
comprends pas bien
tout à l'heure vous avez mentionné une
série de baisses de d'imposition qui
avaient été réalisés ces derniers mois
sur les murs on a commencé à voir
apparaître des affiches qui demande dans
quel pays est ce que l'impôt sur le
revenu a diminué de 10% en deux ans soit
comprendre que c'est la france
et pourtant dans l'avait pas constaté
sur votre feuille d'impôts oui si
absolument me voir que beaucoup de gens
l'ont constaté mais en regardant la
dernière brochure le décembre de l'insee
je constate autre chose c'est que
globalement la pression fiscale en 86
ans 87 a augmenté par comme par rapport
à 86 de 0,2 pour atteindre 25 23
alors si tout baisse et que la pression
fiscale augmente mais il assure fiscal
c'est-à-dire en dehors des des
prélèvements sociaux il n'y a pas que
l'état monsieur du roi il ya eu s'il est
prêt la pression fiscale pour une faible
part la sécurité sociale très faible et
une part de fiscalité dans les
ressources a signé sociale il y a les
collectivités locales
et il ya les prélèvements pour l'europe
et tout cela a augmenté
c'est pourquoi je considère que l'effort
que nous avons à faire dans les années
qui viennent
concerne race est certes toujours la
fiscalité d'état mais devra également
être étendue à la fiscalité locale et
disons à la fiscalité sociale
c'est-à-dire aux prélèvements sociaux
est ce que vous me permettrez de dire
quelque chose sur la relation entre la
sécurité sociale et le chômage
c'est extrêmement important les français
ont le sentiment que la sécurité sociale
est gravement menacée et ils en sont
extrêmement inquiets et ils ont raison
d'ailleurs car c'est véritablement
quelque chose qu'il faut préserver
savez vous combien coûte le chômage à la
sécurité sociale en paix
art de recettes ou en dépenses
supplémentaires plus de 200 milliards de
francs plus de 200 milliards de francs
ça veut dire que le jour où nous
parviendrons à commencer à régler le
problème du chômage et c'est pourquoi je
suis tellement heureux que nous ayons
déjà stopper cette dégradation qu'ils
appliquent commencé à régler le problème
du chômage à dire augmenter augmenter
les emplois actif dans notre société on
perdait à peu près cent mille emplois
par an dans les années 80 86 nous avons
stoppé cette dégradation depuis deux ans
le nombre d'emplois même très légèrement
augmenté en fait vous l'avez pas
réellement stopper ça a connu une bosse
et ses revenus non je ne parle pas du
chômage parle des créations d'emplois à
l'occasion je parle des créations
d'emplois nous l'avons stoppée
eh bien il faudra faire mieux que le
stopper il faudra créer de nouveaux
emplois et lorsque nous créeront de
nouveaux emplois le chômage diminuera et
la sécurité sociale sera en meilleur
équilibre yves mai mais pour créer de
nouveaux emplois
il faut je dis les choses très simples
il faut produire plus et pour vendre ce
qu'on produit il faut exporter et pour
l'exporter il faut le produire à un prix
plus faible grâce à une meilleure
compétitivité
tout le problème de la france d'ici la
fin du siècle c'est celui de janvier à
votre terme qu'il temporise ait pas de
confusion quand vous dites il faut
commencer à régler le problème du
chômage
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parce qu'on a
connu c'est pas si longtemps des
promesses inconsidérées
kiki qui s'engageait à régler le
problème du chômage
on a vu ce que ça donnait dans quelles
proportions
alors j'ai du mal m'exprimer j'ai du mal
m'exprimer
il y a deux choses dans le problème du
chômage
il y a d'abord les postes actifs les
emplois nous avons stoppé la dégradation
la france ne perd plus d'emplois ça
c'est déjà agréé qui est j'ai dit il
faut faire mieux il faut créer des
emplois nous et puis il ya une deuxième
chose c'est les chômeurs et bien pour la
première fois depuis 1973 sous la main
fait très nouveau le nombre de chômeurs
en france a diminué sept ou huit mois de
suite
d'à peu près cent trente mille si je
veux aller jusqu'où
cette baisse aux ça dépend de beaucoup
de choses à dire le vrai il y a
plusieurs façons de régler le problème
il ya plusieurs façons de régler le
problème ou bien en créant de vrais
emplois et c'est un transfert du chômage
vers les vrais emplois ou bien en
développant tout ce qui est formation
qui est fort important formations
contrats de conversion situation de
transition ce que c'est ce que nous
faisons actuellement grâce notamment aux
collectivités locales qui sont associés
pour permettre à chacun d'avoir un
minimum d'activités vins revenir donc je
ne voudrais pas vous laisser les chiens
le sentiment que nous n'avons que le
chômage ait pas un problème
nous commençons à le résoudre nous
sommes loin du compte mais nous
commençons devrait revenir un instant à
la fiscalité est ce que vous êtes de
ceux qui trouvent normal ou anormal que
11 millions de foyers fiscaux ne paie
pas d'impôt sur le revenu en france
voyez je sais que c'est un débat et
qu'on me reproche on me reproche d'avoir
fait en sorte que 4000 que deux millions
de français de foyers ne fait plus
d'impôt du tout et que deux autres
millions paix 30% au titre on ne
reproche deux équipes françaises groupe
dans tous les horizons
décidément c'est une idée fixe à d'un à
qui pensez vous la mettez moi je pense
que la personne en particulier un peu
dans tous les gens disent que j'ai
réussi à vous mettre dans la tête alors
dans tous les horizons un peu dans tous
les horizons et bien je vais vous dire
ma façon de voir
je sais bien que certains disent l'impôt
c'est un devoir et aussi modeste que
l'on soit on devrait payer ne serait-ce
que 50 francs d'impôts ou 100 francs
d'impôts pour marquer connaît un citoyen
comme les autres et que l'on doit
prendre sa part aux dépenses de la
collectivité mais est la france n'est
pas l'allemagne on n'est pas
l'angleterre en france ya deux
caractéristiques on paie beaucoup
d'impôts indirects et il pèse davantage
sur les petits revenus
proportionnellement de sur les grands et
on paie des cotisations sociales plus
importante qui moins de revenus qui elle
aussi est ce davantage sur les petits
revenus que sur les grands et on paie
moins d'impôt sur le revenu
alors si on veut touré faut réformer
tout cela on peut en discuter c'est une
affaire de très très longue haleine vous
savez une dimension gigantesque les
français dans leur histoire ont toujours
manifesté une profonde allergie à
l'impôt sur le revenu qu'ils sont ainsi
faire mais je me sens tout à fait à
l'aise pour défendre les baisses
d'impôts auxquels j'ai procédé la
diminution du nombre de français qui
paie l'impôt direct parce que la france
est un pays où on paie des cotisations
sociales plus importante qu'ailleurs et
où on paie un impôt sur le revenu plus
important qu'ailleurs je trouve que ceci
compense cela et même au delà d'ailleurs
puisque globalement la france est un
pays plus imposés que les pays voisins
est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
souhaitent une grande réforme fiscale de
ces grandes récentes dont on parle
souvent
il faudrait savoir exactement laquelle
n'est ce pas ses traits à métro grand
tout en chantier et on revoit tout ça
c'est très dangereux il faut je préfère
qu'on procède par petites touches et
progressivement les très grande réforme
fiscale risque de susciter beaucoup plus
de mécontentement que de satisfactions
on n'est jamais très sûr de l'effet
économique ou sociale de ce que l'on
fait il ya des choses qu on mesure mal
souvenez-vous de la taxe professionnelle
dès hier jeudi tout en plus volontiers
que c'est là la majorité actuelle alors
qu'elle était et déjà la majorité qui
l'a instituée donc c'est à elle que
revient la responsabilité c'est
extrêmement difficile je préfère qu'on
procède progressivement
je ne me permettrais pas de dire qui
l'autre jour sur une radio demandé une
grande réforme fiscale pour la france
mais on peut très bien y réfléchir je
suis tout à fait partisan d'y réfléchir
un tout petit mois avant de passer à
tout autre chose
un tout petit mot sur l'emprunt giscard
qu'on rembourse ces jours ci vous étiez
en janvier 73 se fait en général adjoint
de l'elysée oui est ce que vous aviez tu
es ce que l'elysée ou vous-même vous
aviez été consultés ce que vous avez
donné un avis est un avis positif
je donnais mon avis au président de la
république de l'époque qui je devais et
vous ne tenez pas dire quel était cet
avis non est-ce que a plus que les avis
que j'ai pu lui donner sur des tas
d'autres sujets que le ministre des
finances que vous êtes aujourd'hui
considèrent que cet emprunt giscard a
été une erreur
non non je ne le crois pas parce que
l'histoire financière de la france s'est
faite d un des emprunts qui ont grugé
les épargnants on pourrait vous savez en
faire un florilège
pour une fois il ya un emprunt qui
a été assez favorable aux épargnants ac
oui assez favorable aux et par un
mécanisme assez favorable aux épargnes
et bien écoutez je trouve que il ya une
chose qui prime toutes les autres c'est
que l'état doit tenir sa parole l'état
était engagée par sa signature il ne m'a
pas il ne m'est pas venu à l'idée une
seule seconde
c'est pas la question n'est pas de ne
pas respecter intégralement l'obligation
du contrat notez qu'on aborde un autre
problème dans les journaux on parlait
pas mal ces jours ci qui est ce qu'ils
ont présentées vous allez nous dire si
c'est la vérité ou pas comme une espèce
de différent avec votre collègue de
l'éducation nationale monsieur rené
monory qui propose dans le cadre d'un
plan très ambitieux de réformes de
l'enseignement qui va coûter 28
milliards sont souviens bien qui propose
notamment l'augmentation des salaires
des enseignants en augmentation de 10 à
15 % de tous les salaires et on dit que
le ministère des finances n'est pas
d'accord ce que vous évoquez c'est un
rapport qui a été fait par monsieur le
sourne qui est un homme tout à fait
respectable et compétent qui l'a remis à
monsieur monory dont monsieur monory a
fait une conférence de presse en prenant
en reprenant à son compte en exprime un
certain nombre de sous et sans dire qui
reprenait tout à son contenant mais en
dix ans en disant même que le
gouvernement engagerait sa fin février
alors ce qu'il a été convenu entre le
premier ministre monsieur monory
monsieur juppé moi même c'est que nous
nous réunissions pour étudier cette
affaire pour chiffrer les propositions
qui sont faites car moi j'ai besoin en
tant que ministre des finances d'avoir
un chiffrage précis et de savoir
exactement où on va 25 milliards ce
n'est pas rien même étalé sur plusieurs
années
et une fois que nous aurons ces
propositions précises et ce chiffrage et
bien nous proposerons monsieur au
gouvernement de prendre une orientation
est ce que vous pensez que globalement
les salaires des enseignants doivent
être revalorisées ce que ce serait
souhaitable
on dit ça de beaucoup de catégories on
le dit des magistrats on le dit des
officiers qui remplissent avec beaucoup
de désintéressement
des obligations souvent rude et adam les
contraintes familiales sont très lourdes
on le dit beaucoup de catégories on le
dit des gardiens de prison policiers en
2000 il faut trouver 150 mille
enseignants est ce que c'est avec les
salaires qu'ils ont aujourd'hui qu'on va
trouver des enseignants de qualité
c'est une question il faut y réfléchir
mais il faut se demander si cela ne
passe pas par une réforme profonde des
méthodes d'organisation de l'éducation
nationale et de la répartition du temps
de travail dans l'année
est-ce que je pense tout à fait de
sujets pardon est-ce que vous avez une
idée du prix de location que l'état
major de campagne de jacques chirac va
payer au gan assurances nationale pour
l'immeuble que dégainent leurs loups
n'ont pas la moindre
je ne savais même pas que c'était le gan
qui leur est ce qu est ce que est ce
qu'il vous semblerait normal que le
président gagnent les nationaliser
encore une fois encore nationaliser
révèle 10 quel est le prix tu es payé
trop tout à fait il me semblerait
surtout normal qu'il demande à un prix
tout à fait normal aussi
c'est ça oui mais ça fait partie de la
transparence que tout à fait la loi va
aurait là bas tout à fait le budget de
la campagne des candidats devra être
public et devra être plafonnés je trouve
ça très bien j'ai toujours pensé que
l'argent toujours un trop grand rôle
dans la politique et que la morale n'ont
joué pas toujours un assez grand donc je
suis tout à fait partisan de ce genre de
texte et dans dans le cadre de ce projet
de loi sur le financement des partis et
vous étiez de ceux qui défendent l idée
que le
les parties doivent être financées par
l'argent public c'est à dire par l'impôt
ou bien de ceux qui disent non il faut
qu'un financement privé je suis un peu
partagé parce que le financement privé
depuis que j'ai fait voter cette loi sur
le mécénat ça veut dire un financement
avec l'exonération fiscale donc de toute
manière ça ne coûte quelque chose à
l'état ou bien il donne une subvention
budgétaire ou bien ils donnent une
exonération fiscale
je crois qu'on n'y échappe pas je veux
dire qu'on n'échappe pas au fait que
dans une collectivité
il est normal que le fonctionnement de
la démocratie et le fonctionnement de la
vie politique coûte quelque chose à la
collectivité et ce où que ce soit par
l'impôt que ce soit par les exonérations
fiscales ça revient à peu près au même
tout est une question de mesure et de
proportions il faut pas aller trop loin
il faut pas admettre des versements trop
importants exonérés d'impôts par exemple
utile et il faut pas davantage admettent
que l'état accorde des subventions trop
importante aux partis politiques ils en
accorde déjà aux syndicats et dans la
gorge a eu toute une série d'organismes
il est peut être légitime qu'il en
accorde parti politique mais dans une
mesure qui doit être soigneusement dosé
toute petite question
ces affiches dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui vante la politique du
gouvernement parquet ont été en thelle
été payée écouter l'orgue pour le coup
je n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien il
s'agit d' affiches qui ont été faites
par le cid
c'est ça bon alors elles ont dû être
payées sur les crédits normaux du cid
qui sont des crédits d'état est-ce que
ça devrait être comptabilisée dans les
100 millions de campagne de jacques
chirac en général ça n'est pas le cas
souvenez vous que le gouvernement
précédent avait fait une publicité du
même genre d'ailleurs même beaucoup plus
importante et du mans
qui n'était d'ailleurs pas le préambule
d'une campagne présidentielle mais d'une
campagne législative si ma mémoire est
bonne donc là là il faut la continuité
il faut s'interroger la question que
vous posez quand même une vraie question
vous interrogez parce que même si le
gouvernement fait de la publicité pour
expliquer que ce qu'il a fait n'est pas
trop mal il n'empêche que si on
considère que si on est convaincu par
cette publicité ça peut influer sur le
vote c'est tout à fait vrai j'étais
encore à une dernière question dans la
dernière heure de vérité je vous avais
fait une suggestion et j'en ai tellement
entendu parler le lendemain que je me
suis dit que c'était peut-être une bonne
suggestion et qu'il fallait vous reposer
la question d'autant plus que l'avenir
est promis d'y réfléchir
c'était d'accorder un bonus aux bons
contribuables à ceux qui ne trichait
jamais est-ce que vous avez réfléchi
depuis deux ans oui depuis 18 16 mois ce
qui ne triche jamais oui il faudrait
contrôler tout le monde pour être sûr
que personne ne triche
ce serait un alourdissement du contrôle
fiscal votre proposition car c'est pas
une proposition c'était une suggestion
comme ça bien alors j'ai envie de scène
quatre petites questions
oui à votre avis monsieur le ministre
faudrait-il une amnistie notamment
fiscales après l'élection présidentielle
si jacques chirac est élu au l'amnistié
fiscale monsieur est quasi de faim
sinon de règle du moins d'usagers comme
un certain nombre d'autres amnistie et
je pense que qu'il s'agisse de jacques
chirac ou de tout autre candidat c'est
une question qu'il se posera
le tout est de savoir jusqu'où l'on va
bien entendu plusieurs fiches pour une
même question accepteriez-vous bientôt
de rencontrer andré lajoinie pour un
débat de fond sur les questions
économiques
j'ai déjà rencontré michel rocard je
veux bien rencontrer d'autres et
pourquoi pas monsieur lajoinie deux
dernières questions plus personnelles
comment ressentez-vous la caricature du
dessinateur plantu dans le monde qui
vous représente comme un petit marquis
avec amusement
dernière question quel est le trait de
caractère que vous appréciez le plus
chez jacques chirac et celui que vous
appréciez le moins ce que j'apprécie le
plus c'est la loyauté envers ses amis et
sa fidélité et sa générosité tout ça va
ensemble si vous voulez s'il faut
absolument que je dis ce que j'apprécie
le moins
je dirais que c'est ce que je viens de
dire c'est que la générosité qu'il a est
extrêmement grande
[Musique]
bien et vient voici venu donc l'heure du
verdict et je vais me retourner vers la
sofres qui a donc télé sont dépendants
toute cette soirée les réactions des
français qui vous regarder et qui va
vous dire dans quelle mesure vous avez
d'abord fait bonne impression et
deuxièmement ce qui est peut-être plus
important réussi à faire bouger
l'opinion des français jérôme jaffré
directeur des études politiques de la
sofres monsieur balladur s'est présenté
ce soir à la fois comme le ministre des
finances du problème de liaison
je crois que si la liaison est
définitivement interrompue c'est après
la fin des jeux nous arrive je suis pour
rien bon non là on a la liaison alors
jérôme jaffré vous repartez vous
repartez à 0 monsieur balladur s'est
présenté ce soir à la fois comme bien
sûr comme le ministre de l'économie et
des finances mais aussi comme un leader
politique donnant le premier coup
d'envoi de la campagne électorale de
jacques chirac la surprise que nous
enregistrons c'est que le leader
politique a presque davantage réussi que
le ministre de l'économie
nous l'avons mesurée à travers une série
de questions au cours de l'émission
d'abord une question sur les
conséquences de la politique économique
du gouvernement
nous l'avons posée juste avant le début
nous l'avons posée à la fin
est ce que la politique économique du
gouvernement a des conséquences
positives des conséquences négatives où
aucun effet nous avions posé la même
question il ya 16 mois pour la première
heure de vérité de monsieur balladur
la comparaison est donc intéressant ce
soir 38 % de réponses effet positif en
fin d'émission 27% effets négatifs
quatre points deux gagnés sur les effets
positifs en cours d'émission
mais il y à 16 mois sa première heure de
vérité monsieur balladur avait gagné 8
points sur cette question et avait
terminé légèrement plus haut toutefois
je note que les réponses sont en
majorité plutôt positives que négatives
deuxième série de questions est ce que
monsieur balladur s'est montré
convaincant sur les grandes questions
qu'il a abordés au cours de cette heure
de vérité
nous l'avons mesurée sur les solutions à
apporter aux problèmes économiques
internationaux sur le soutien qu'ils
apportent à jacques chirac et enfin sur
un thème qu'il souhaitait aborder qu'il
a pu aborder en fin d'émission le bilan
du gouvernement sur ces trois thèmes
une majorité de personnes interrogées
par la sofres se sont déclarés
convaincus par les propos de monsieur
balladur sur les problèmes économiques
internationaux 49% de convaincu 36% pas
convaincu sur le bilan du gouvernement
47 % contre 40 %
et surprise c'est sur le soutien à
jacques chirac pour la présidentielle
que monsieur balladur s'est montré le
plus convaincant 56 % de réponses
positives 10
% de réponses négatives il ne faut quand
même pas y voir là une expression d'une
préférence politique car par exemple 34
% des sympathisants des partis de gauche
ont trouvé monsieur balladur convaincant
sur les idées les thèmes qu'il a
développés sur le soutien à jacques
chirac
enfin dernière question notre question
traditionnelle sur la bonne et la
mauvaise opinion que l'on a à l'égard de
l'inviter en début et en fin d'émission
monsieur balladur a commencé cette
émission assez haut puisqu'il a eu 51%
d'opinions positives alors qu'il ya 16
mois il avait commencé avec seulement
35% de bonnes opinions il termine
l'émission avec 57 % de bonnes opinions
32 % de mauvaises
il gagne 6 points en cours d'émission
mais il termine un peu moins haut que
l'année dernière puisqu'il avait terminé
là avec 63 % de bonnes opinions
je crois que ont peu avancé plusieurs
raisons d'abord l'effet de découverte
qu'avec monsieur balladur il ya seize
mois a évidemment moins joué ce soir
ensuite que la situation économique est
plus difficile surtout sur le plan
international qu'il ya 16 mois et enfin
je dirais que si un leader politique
comme l'est devenu monsieur balladur
peut se montrer convaincant il est plus
difficile d'être populaire voilà un mot
de commentaires mais celui d'état non
aucun commentaire bien eh bien nous
allons maintenant si et le livre d'or
vous souhaiter une bonne année et
prochain rendez vous le mercredi 27
janvier
monsieur jean marie le pen pour soins
[Musique]